being an island I mean being just a the
fact that you guys are so big
geographically and that your and I and
how much of that actually plays into
sorta the national ethos because you
know like when we see what's going on
with the European Union and borders and
all that stuff these are people that are
landlocked next to each other you know
borders and immigration are important
all that kind of stuff and you guys
really have the advantage of water I
mean it really is just that simple in a
way but how much is that actually like
affect policies and the way people think
about the rest of the world and all that
kind of stuff oh look we've got oceans
and yeah geographically we are blessed
to be apart from a lot of that turmoil
but those oceans didn't stop 50,000
people come in here by boat when labor
was in government we had a very strict
border control system under the
Conservative government of John Howard
and when labor were elected they
completely dismantle that because that's
not that wasn't in their thinking they
thought it was more humane to to be a
little bit more tolerant but that
tolerance led to hundreds of people over
1200 people drowning on our borders
trying to come here from places like
Indonesia bye-bye they weren't
Indonesians they travel from them
typically the Middle East right so there
are migrants actually from other
countries that use Indonesia's right
keeping the economic migrants I'm sure
there was some genuine refugees amongst
them but the overwhelming majority you
would describe as economic migrants and
even the Labour Party came to
acknowledge that and they started
toughening up and right now they're well
they say they back all the border
protection policies that the
conservative side have and and you know
they're not going to dismantle
everything because it led to enormous
suffering not just the 1200 people who
drowned trying to get here women and
children amongst them but also all-out
detention centers filled you know we
have 50 we have just 50,000 I think even
more than that in detention centers you
know effectively locked up and since
we've managed to take regain control of
our borders so
detention centers of empty doubt there's
not people drowning on the border and we
still have our refugee program we still
have a humanitarian intake in fact we've
increased it but we select people who
are waiting and observing the rules
because you know what people there was a
period where people would argue that
there are no queues to come here you
know these programs don't exist but as
we know they do exist and there's people
floundering waiting in camps who don't
have the resources to hop on a plane to
Indonesia and then pay a people smuggler
to come by boat to Australia and then
our priority so we a refugee and take I
think is something to really be really
proud of because we are very generous
with that and you know this isn't just
simply porous borders this is a proper
humanitarian program where these people
are brought here they're given housing
health care education and you know help
to to become integrated into society but
Rita Rita I thought you were supposed to
be a cold-hearted heartless conservative
who wants to close borders and all that
but it it sounds like you're actually
okay with immigration as you were an
immigrant yourself but you just want you
just want reasonable standards to let
Emma we've got this country particularly
economically needs our economic migrants
they bring a great deal of wealth and
you know we're an aging nation we need
people to who are working age and come
here and are productive and contribute
well our humanitarian intake we've got
to be honest it cost us a lot of money
but it is something I think that as a
rich nation were obliged to do and I'm
proud of that however that doesn't mean
that it's a free-for-all and whoever you
know I can just break the rules come
here can come here first also we've got
to be mindful of where those refugees
are coming from because of late there
has been issues with some not
integrating as they should and as
immigrants decades before them have
integrated so there is a lot of debate
in this country about where should these
refugees come from you know where do we
do we prioritize Christians
being persecuted in in the middlee CDs
or do we not consider religion at all
and just bring in whoever's you know
deemed the neediest there was a poll
just this week that was published those
absolutely blowing people away it was a
it was a poll that was you know why one
of the more left-leaning posters so you
know there can be no sort of accusations
and you know it was published in The
Guardian says the campaign accusations
of this was some sort of rogue poll to
to try to change public sentiment but it
showed one in two Australians supports
an immediate ban on Muslim migration now
this has absolutely shocked so many
people who just refused to accept that
this sort of sentiment is out there and
it's there because people don't talk
about this issue people pretend that you
know terrorism isn't happening but it
doesn't have really Jen and and you know
most Australians are smarter than that
now I don't actually agree with
immediate ban on Muslim migration I'm
not for that at all but I can understand
and and the poll didn't surprise me
because you know I don't exist in this
little tiny echo chamber that so many of
the media seem to exist in where yeah I
just think we need to talk about these
things openly cuz when you don't that's
when you have sent him and like this
rising and I don't think it's
particularly healthy so isn't that the
ultimate irony of your position for you
particularly because as an immigrant
from the Middle East it's it's extremely
personal to you but for me and the
people that are in our space that we see
on Twitter that are talking about this
stuff that aren't doing it from a
bigoted place that want to help people
when we can and all that but also what a
proper bedding they've put us in a
really bizarre situation and for you I
mean I've seen you go on TV and you know
I saw something where you were on TV
debating this guy an anchor and he kept
implying you were saying all Muslims
repeatedly even even though you never
said it will link to it below so people
can see it
you never said it it was the it was the
age-old argument that we have all the
time here and it's like man she's from
the Middle East she was born to Muslim
parents she immigrated properly now
she's trying
to stand up for the very values that
this country is for and they're doing
this to you to this bizarro alliance
between the regressive left and
Islamists it is prevalent everywhere you
know in the UK the US and even in
Australia and it is bloody sick it
doesn't make any sense the only sense it
makes is that they share a common enemy
conservatives but yeah I think you're
talking about a appearance on morning
television where I had written a piece
about yeah yeah this Tara has a religion
and we've got to acknowledge it again I
was at pains as we always are to say I'm
talking about Islam as I'm talking about
the extremists I'm not talking about the
thing timeless the money you know you
all those qualifications were made but
no nevertheless you know even just
talking about it even in identifying
what is happening then it's clear to
anybody who hasn't got their head buried
in the sand
well so pour into this student and he
brought up Christian terrorism you know
bombings and abortion clinics which I
think you know the last one was he could
find was about 15 20 years ago but
nevertheless you know you can't talk
about Muslim based or isn't a space
terror without mentioning the Christian
you know it's just he also it was pretty
great because you asked him when the
last one was and he had no idea then he
busted out his phone and a few minutes
later came back and yeah it turned out
to be 15 or 20 years ago I'm curious you
know because you guys haven't been hit
with terrorism really until about two
years ago in Sydney and there was that
hostage situation and all that was how
much did that actually change the
discussion for you guys because you were
seeing it everywhere else again
surrounded by water seemingly safe yeah
did that really change the discussion in
the country okay did the Lindt cafe
stage in Sydney and did as sued him and
there's been other events here just a
short time before that there was a young
kid in Melbourne who was radicalized and
he tried to kill a couple of police
officers stabbed
repeatedly he was shot dead that was
probably you know our first taste of it
lint affected the public it wasn't just
targeted at police but we've been really
fortunate in this country we've had our
counterterrorism officers and
authorities for several plots we've just
had some someone imprisoned for what was
it called the Anzac Day terror plot a
really significant day within our within
our calendar the plot there was to run
over a police officer behead them take
their gun and shoot more people we've
had a mother's day plot that's with
before the courts now which was again
you know gonna be targeting the public
from the information that's out there
and so there's there's been and and the
biggest one we had was all about a
decade ago not longer no about a decade
ago which was quite advanced plans to
bomb the Melbourne Cricket Ground which
is our biggest sporting stadium here so
we've been really fortunate that these
plots have been stopped in their tracks
but those lone wolf attacks as we call
them they're not so easily stopped and
and it has been a we had a police member
shot in Sydney last year you know in
attack by a young kid I think was 15 16
who was again radicalized so we've had a
taste of it but nowhere like you know
places like France and Belgium where
their issues seem to be so advanced that
you want to have ever gonna get on top
of it yeah is that the irony to is that
it's like the better that our security
services are the more things that they
stop and often we don't know that they
stop them until sometimes months or
years later and then at the same time it
makes the threat seem lower so then
people want to be more tolerant and
again tolerance basically is good but
you don't have a full picture and I
guess that's really what the the big
issue is absolutely you can become
complacent you know we don't live in
fear here we don't think you know we're
going to be blown up around the street
corner but again you've just got to be
awake to the reality of what's happening
or
the world and that we are not immune
from it you know the terror denies
around here will bring up things like oh
you've got much more chance of you know
dying in a car crash course you bloody
do you know we drive around we've got
millions of cars but you know do we not
think about terror and we don't worry
about that and make sure we kept doing
things to counter it you know do we not
worry about domestic violence because
more people are dying on the roads from
car accidents I mean it is just a stupid
argument there is just so much that is
intellectually dishonest and and just
fraudulent in my mind when it comes to
this space because people will do
anything not to talk about it people
will do anything to deny that it's even
an issue and it obviously is an issue
and this poll that came out this week
shows that it is an issue and people are
thinking about it even if our elite
media and politicians aren't willing to
discuss it
yeah can you think of anything else that
we're so paralyzed to talk about because
I really can't in 2016 is there anything
else that we treat with such kid gloves
that is of such importance and I said I
get email from people literally all over
the world from almost every country
saying that their governments are doing
the exact same thing yeah it seems to
yeah not be every Western nation seems
to be dealing with it in Australia I
think the other issue that is seems to
be taboo but is a significant issue is
what's happening in a lot of our
indigenous communities again it's
something that people don't talk about
because if you do talk about it you can
get labeled racist very quickly even
though you care enough to want to
actually do something about an attack
police put it on the public to publicly
discuss it even we've got kids who are
being really mistreated and neglected
and they're not being saved by the
authorities they're not being taken into
care at the same level as you would
expect I mean sorry let me rephrase that
they actually are taken into care at
greater rates then then the non-indian
community but at the point where the
authorities take them seems to be a you
know a lot higher than then you know but
no white kid I don't think would be
allowed to be mistreated in that way for
so long before they are saved and we
were thought there's no stolen
generation narrative in our history that
that the authorities are scared now to
actually save kids who are being abused
and and because of that political
correctness because they don't want to
create another stolen generation of
indigenous kids taken from their parents
but those kids are condemned to just
terrible lives you know that they repeat
the cycle they and I think that's just
such a great shame and there is that
there is a really significant gap in in
living standards and life expectancy in
outcomes Brad did Yunus community
compared to the non-indigenous community
and I believe a great deal of that has
to do with this politically correct
policies where we can't talk about
what's happening we can't talk about the
rampant abuse sexual abuse we can't talk
about the alcoholism the drug use
because to even start discussing it is
is racist you know their arguments will
come out what about all the drug use and
alcoholism in the non-indigenous
community well yes of course but that
doesn't stop yeah it's exactly the same
sort of phenomenon happening there and
it's just as destructive and it actually
hurts the people that they are trying to
protect from from discussion right and
we see that we see that exact same thing
when it comes to the discussion on Islam
because if we don't talk about it then
who are you hurting the most you're
actually hurting Muslim people who are
living under these theocracies the
people who are yeah killed the most and
oppressed the most are other Muslims and
you know Islamic state looks at Shiite
Muslims like my family as infidels no
different from from Jews or
non-believers
gays you know they think they're
deserving of nothing of death as well so
and extremist Islamists have been
killing other Muslims you know at a rate
that is extraordinary for decades and we
just don't it's almost not on our radar
anymore because it happens so often
well Reid or whatever there is what
about the abortion bombing in the
Crusades well that's it William what
about the Crusades
I mean God say some of the arguments
that are thrown up I just just they're
just too stupid but you've got to
acknowledge them and you've got to
counter them because they've been taught
in universities you know I've had these
sort of arguments with university
lecturers and journalists and you know
peer academics who are on the public
purse and I just spewing forth
and it's maddening spewing forth
that could be the title of a
book that we should probably call write
that book so jumping back for a second
talking about Australia's role in the
world what what is the Australian sort
of ethos about what you feel your role
should be obviously you guys aren't that
interventionist but you've been part of
coalition's and things like that what is
the the feeling there of what your
purpose in the world should be well
putting light back about things we don't
try to sort of set the agenda or you
know enforce our belief systems but yeah
we we have been a good corporates
corporate we've been a good global
citizen oh man that Freudian slip is
gonna be replayed many many times we can
be proud of involvement in World War two
our involvement you know with the Allied
forces and I think you know we do feel a
little bit removed geographically we are
so far from so much of what's happening
around the world but these days you know
it's all there in your hand and you're
furthering it's it's a media you know
what's happening as soon as it happens
you know that's it's we're living in a
time where you know those those borders
don't seem to mean as much so
I think we're fairly relaxed about our
place in the world you know we do have
those amongst us as you have in every
community who want to set the agenda
they want to be you know we had a carbon
tax for a while and you know that
rationale was there we you know we're
going to lead the world in an emission
trading scheme we're going to be the
standard bearers in a fight in global
warming and uh that government got
thrown out really quickly so yeah that
didn't that didn't last too long so I
think overall my Australians recognized
a pretty lucky we got a very good
standard of living we've got our own
concerns all sorts of issues from
housing affordability to the threat of
terror but I think we're yeah we're
pretty happy with seeing what's
happening around the world and and and
feeling fortunate that it's not
happening in our back yard yet yeah it's
I'm telling you it's that water thing
being big and surrounded by water it's
it's pretty good what do you what do you
make of our crazy election here and not
only what do you make of it
but what kind of coverage in Australia
just in mainstream media is our election
getting because it's all we it's all we
have here any of the cable news 24-hour
days that's all we talk about are we
getting a lot a lot more than previously
there is a lot of American election
coverage in our mainstream news
particular television a great deal of it
and all of it almost all of it is pretty
much what you'd expect it's very much
you know Trump is this maniac who's a
racist and sexist and you know some of
the reports I've seen which is mostly
just straight news reports have been
again extraordinary in being little you
know editorials that are absolutely
biased personally I don't know what I
mean I've got a
great deal of thoughts I'm not a fan of
a candidate I can't be enthusiastic for
Trump but I completely understand the
phenomenon I understand people being
utterly fed up and wanting
anti-establishment figure and I know why
appeals to people I think a lot of
things that the the media see is gaps
and sees huge errors in his character
actually enormous assets and I would
appeal to a lot of people so it's been
just fascinating I would love to be
there for the last month or two and just
see how it unfolds but you know Trump
some of his greatest enemies are again
his greatest assets you look at what's
happening now with the protests in in
Charlotte and you know the protests that
were happening at his rallies and you
think the average American looking at
that would actually sympathize with
would sympathy would understand some of
the things he's been saying about what
the country has turned into you know
Charlotte is just extraordinary you've
got a black cop shooting and seems to be
an armed black man and the place is
being torn apart and our black purchase
does shot another black protester but
it's in a city with a Democratic mayor
yeah it is why she's fault somehow
you know this black on black violence
it's happened and somehow cause for just
looting and beatings and just mass
mindless violence that's been
characterized as some sort of a protest
that's got some purpose and it doesn't
it is just mindless looting and violence
and it should be called what it is and
again I think the public can see what it
is but the media narrative is trying to
paint it as something other than that I
think that is a great thing as something
else we have in common in Australia in
America you Europe is the media being
out of touch with its readers viewers
listeners they are just increasingly
there's a gap between members of the
media and the mainstream
population on I think that's not healthy
yeah I think it's interesting to use the
phrase out of touch because I think one
of the debates were constantly having
here and the reason that online shows
are working is that it's it is it out of
touch or is it that they're actually in
it with the politicians do you think
it's it's like a sort of generational
thing and just the technology thing and
you know we're all walking around with
phones so now we're all on the ground
journalist or or is it that they're
actually in it with the people in power
so they have a vested interest in
keeping that game going or maybe both
well in the u.s. it might be a bit of
that or in Australia I think it is that
I think it's because they're part of the
establishment or the elite I think it's
just the ideological disposition of a
great number of the members of the media
and it's it's it's great many of them
are not
you know then look at the mainstream
will one that only acknowledge the
mainstream is actually mainstream know
they think quite often things because
they're surrounded by like-minded people
that their views are the prevalence
views and they're not or they just look
at the mainstream with sort of
condemnation as if they're too stupid to
believe what they believe and I think
it's again really unhealthy at a time
where the mainstream media needs it
needs its audience more than ever to be
poles apart from from what their great
majority of the population thinks I
think is really unfortunate yeah and I
in Australia anyway I think it's just a
simple matter of the politics of the
individuals within the media tends to be
very much on the left as it has in your
been for for generations and and the
remember the rest of the population is a
lot more diverse than that it's a lot
more nuanced than that you know and and
their views aren't being properly
reflected of course there are
conservative commentators and writers
and journalists but I'm very much in the
minority and and not reflecting the
number of voters who are leaning that
way how much of this stuff do you think
is actually just purely the fault of
Education
be it in Australia or be it here or
wherever I mean I was watching the the
Charlotte the riots and there was this
guy you know they found a protester and
he was screaming about Trump and I'll
preface this with saying this is not a
defense of Trump but Trump is not in
power now he's not the president or the
governor of the state or the mayor of
that city and the guy was blaming Trump
and it's like I'm not saying you should
be blaming Hillary and I'm not even
saying you should be blaming Obama but
your your misdirecting things at
somebody that has literally nothing to
do no power in place has anything to do
with Trump right now and to me that's an
education problem not a political
problem very much and yeah if those
opinions come from ignorance but they
are supported again by quite often by
mainstream media now remember you know
after even Orlando that was talked about
yeah Trump as if he had anything to do
with you know after the Orlando Massacre
it is just absurd to be blaming him I
mean we can you imagine how this news
would be reported if it was a bunch of
Trump supporters who were tearing apart
a city who were you know bashing
bystanders or just the color of their
skin who were looting in there and just
causing this wide strength widespread
mayhem and destruction yeah yeah it is
it is completely idiotic but it's become
almost a joke you know and whenever
something horrible happens around the
world
you know you blame bricks look you blame
Trump you blame the Crusades you know
you can't ever actually pinpoint the
blame at the people responsible because
that would be you know probably racist
and gross
you